[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and welcome to a brand
new my hero academia video now recently
we published videos on the top 10
weakest and strongest works in my ear'
academia and in these videos we focus on
the battle capability of each quirk we
judge the quirks based on how well they
would perform in battle against other
fighters with powerful quirks
however while making these videos we
couldn't help but think that even those
quirks which were not necessarily the
strongest for battle we're still really
useful and in the comments to these
videos many of you pointed this out as
well the quality of a quirk should not
be judged only based on its strength and
combat capability so for this reason and
because you guys requested it in this
video we will be counting down the top
10 best and most useful quirks
for real life by this we mean quirks
that would be extremely useful to us
in the modern world even if they are not
necessarily only meant for combat we
will be judging these quirks based on
how useful they would be to us in our
everyday lives even if no one else in
the world had a quirk except us and this
means that quirks that just copy other
perks or cancel out other quirks or
steal other perks or are only suited for
battle and nothing else will not be
included in this list a big thank you to
everyone who recommended this video and
also thanks to everyone who joined us
live at last week's rant cafe for our
discussion of my hero academia quirks
rant cafe is an anime podcast here on
the channel that we host every Thursday
at 5 p.m. Eastern Standard Time we talk
about hot topics in the world of anime
with other guest youtubers and with you
guys live in the chat so be sure to
check that out finally while making this
video I came across easily over 20
quirks that I thought would be really
useful in real life so if you guys
enjoyed this video and want to see me do
a part 2 be sure to Detroit smash that
like button if we get a bunch of likes I
will definitely make a part 2 and if you
look quickly you
to have it real like that isn't on this
list be sure to leave it in the comments
and I will try to include it in the next
video also some of the characters that
will be mentioned in this video have not
appeared in the enemy yet but while I
will talk about their works I will not
talk about any plot spoilers from the
manga if you are new to the channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and without further
ado let's get into it
number 10 brainwashing an emitter type
quirk that works at long range this
quirk enables its user to literally
control the mind of anyone who says
something back to him he is able to
control and manipulate one or more
people at a time and I'm sure we can
only imagine how useful this work could
be in real life you could use it to get
other people to do your bidding whether
it is getting your younger brother to
mow the lawn for you or trying to take
over the world with your power like
Lelouch does in kolya the user of this
work is class 1c student associations oh
and he has solid control of the quirk he
can talk to people normally without
activating it if he chooses to and he
can then turn around and activate it
when he wants to
however as useful as this quirk would be
in real life the reason it doesn't rank
higher on our list are its many
limitations if the person that the user
wants to control simply says nothing
back to them that work will not activate
and the effects of the perk can also be
broken empty person who has been
affected by it is shocked back into
reality by some significant force such
as pain or the power of one for all as
was the case during Yoshi's fight with
Deku in episode 6 of season 2 of the
anime how would you use this quirk if
you could control the minds of others in
real life let me know down below
number 9 engine a mutant type work that
works at close range this quirk allows
its user to move extremely fast because
of engines that are growing out of the
calves on their legs it is used by tanya
eden the class president of class 1a @
üa these engines actually need orange
juice as fuel and the engines also have
multiple gears that the user
in order to accelerate faster this is
obviously a very useful perk in real
life because who wouldn't love to be
able to move at such great speed and
dominate every school track meet and the
need to drink orange juice isn't a big
drawback
since orange juice is pretty healthy the
one drawback is the fact that the
engines growing out of the users legs
are visible so if you were the only
person with a quirk in the world you
wouldn't be able to keep your power
hidden for a while number eight Fulda
body
a transformation type quirk that works
at close range used by the number-5 pro
hero headshot this work allows its user
to stretch different parts of their body
which gives him great stealth and
agility each shot is able to transform
his body faster than the speed of sound
and he is even able to twist and turn
his own elastic body into a sharp weapon
imagine being able to squeeze through
the narrowest of spaces reach anything
that is out of reach without trouble and
at the same time move so quickly that
others can barely see you you could
sneak up on anyone and sneak into any
place you want which would be pretty
amazing although in the wrong hands this
quirk could be very dangerous for
example if Minoru Minetta had it you
just know he would use it to sneak into
the girls locker room number seven tape
a mutant type quirk that works at long
range this quirk allows its user to
shoot tape from his elbows including
more than one strand of tape at the same
time and the user can also retract them
back into his elbows once he no longer
needs them it is used by hanta Seto from
class 1a the tape itself is actually
very strong it can be used to wrap up
opponents in battle but battles aside it
can also be used to move around by
swinging in the air like spider-man the
amount of tape Seto can discharge at any
given time has a limit and
he uses too much of it he will suffer
physical consequences such as dry skin
but this seems like a small price to pay
for being freakin spider-man number six
clones
an emitter type work that works at long
range this quirk is used by pro-hero
ectoplasm who is also a teacher at UA
the work enables its user to eject an
ectoplasmic material out of his mouth
that can then turn into multiple clones
of himself he is able to create up to 30
or more clones at a time and he can also
create a huge clone that can potentially
trap an opponent inside its body by
devouring them with its giant mouth
because of the many strategic
possibilities that this quirk offers
ectoplasm scores of five out of five and
technique but again even outside of
battle this work is extremely useful
imagine how much work you could get done
if you had 30 clones of yourself doing
it all for you and since the user can
make the clones disappear whenever he
wishes it there is no danger of the
clones becoming a nuisance to your life
when I think about the possibility of
having a clone sit in for me during math
class while I'm at home watching anime I
have no choice but to put this quirk in
the top 10 most useful number five
transparency a mutant type work that
works at close range this quirk allows
its user to be completely invisible to
the naked eye but since the clerk
doesn't apply to clothing this means
that in order to be totally invisible
the user has to be totally naked
transparency is used by Toru haka guru
of class 1a and it appears to work on
the basis of manipulating light because
along with being able to appear
invisible the user can also create
blinding flashes of light and use these
flashes as a weapon against opponents
now the ability to become invisible
would be insanely useful in the real
world you could go unnoticed and get
into any exclusive location you wanted
to you could eavesdrop on people to
learn important information
and you could dominate every single
gable hide and see if you ever wanted to
become something like a spy or assassin
this would be the perfect work for you
but the reason it doesn't rank higher on
our list is that we have never seen
total actually turned at work off while
it would be really useful to be able to
become invisible sometimes I would not
want to have to be invisible all of the
time so if that is the drawback of this
quirk I would not be nearly as inclined
to want it what about you guys will you
still want to have an invisibility quirk
if you couldn't turn it off let me know
in the comments number four permeation a
mutant type work that works at close
range used by medial toccata a third
year you a student this quirk allows its
users body or specific parts of his body
to pass through anything that is either
solid or liquid including walls floors
and ceilings although for the time that
he is permeable he cannot use his senses
and so cannot see or hear anything and
although his clothes will fall off at
this time as well Media is also able to
effectively teleport from one place to
another using his work if he turns off
his work while passing to an object his
body will be quickly shot up from the
object in a way that makes it appear
that he is teleporting from one place to
another through training video is able
to control the direction of the
ejections allowing him to rapidly appear
exactly where he wants to so not only
can me do sneak into any place he wishes
or escape any place he wishes he can do
it so quickly that it looks like he is
teleporting if you've ever felt a desire
to quickly get yourself out of an
awkward situation or avoid someone you
don't want to see or get into an
exclusive Members Only Club this is the
perfect quirk for you it's also pretty
good get out of jail free card if you
ever found yourself in that situation
number three warp gate on a motor type
clerk that works at long range
classified as an extremely rare type of
quirk this quirk allows its user to
create portals out of the black fog that
surrounds him and teleport objects and
people to another location or bring
objects and people from another location
to his current one it is used by pure
beauty one of the most important members
of the league of villains he can use the
fog to hide his own body but his body is
always in there somewhere the only
limitation of this powerful quirk is
that its user must know the exact
location in which the portals are going
to open so guru giddy cannot simply
teleport to wherever Deku is and kidnap
him unless he knows exactly where Deku
is located we do not know the exact
range of this work though we assume that
there must be a limit and kuroky cannot
simply teleport himself to another
continent or anything like that because
that would be crazy
but even if the quirk only works say
within the same city
imagine never being late for any
appointment ever again and never needing
to spend any time in traffic when going
to school or work because you can just
teleport there instantly if you want to
do something more sinister
imagine teleporting inside a bank vault
and leaving with all of the money and if
you ever get caught you can always just
teleport out of the jail this would be a
simply amazing quirk to have in the real
world the only drawback that I see is
that we never see kudo giddy looking
like a normal person
he is always surrounded by the fog this
makes me wonder does he stay like that
to hide his identity or is he stuck
looking like that all of the time like
with the transparency worth I think
warpgate would be an amazing quirk to
have but I wouldn't want to be stuck
looking like Fudo giddy all the time
because in that case people could easily
spot me and recognise that there is
something different about me and again
if I was the only person in the world
with a quirk I certainly wouldn't want
the government trying to capture me to
conduct scientific experiments on me or
anything like that
number two overhaul an emitter type work
that works on contact
this powerful work allows its user to
disassemble anything he touches only to
reassemble it again later it can be used
on inorganic materials like stone or
steel or on organic materials such as
human beings if used on a human being
that person will experience incredible
pain and become incapacitated but if the
user of the quirk wants it then their
body will later be reassembled with all
of their past injuries and illnesses
cured this quirk is used by the leader
of the eighth precept of death
chisaki also known as overhaul ji-suk he
can also use his quirk to break through
walls and then reassemble the walls
behind him to cover his tracks and in
chapter 146 of the manga it is implied
that overhaul could even bring people
back to life if chisaki reassembles them
immediately after they die
using his quirk appears to take a
physical toll on chisaki he develops a
rash and itching but this is a small
price to pay for all the power the clerk
gives its user and we are not even sure
what the full extent of this power is
yet imagine not only being able to break
through walls or fix anything that is
broken by disassembling it and then
reassembling it again but also being
able to cure the illnesses of people
that you care about anyone strangers by
disassembling and reassembling the
affected areas in fact imagine being
able to revive people who died and bring
them back to life with their illnesses
cured which seems like this work might
actually be able to do even though its
power can be terrifying in the right
hands this work could be used to save
many innocent lives and help many
innocent people and for this reason I
had to put it at number two and at
number one is creation an emitter type
Clerk used by momoyo rosu from class 1a
this quirk is able to literally create
any inorganic objects out of its user's
body as long as the skin is exposed in
that particular spot the user cannot
create living things but as long as she
is familiar with the atomic makeup of an
object chica
created by breaking down the fat in her
body on a molecular level and reshaping
it into the desired object the bigger
the object she wants to produce the more
of her skin needs to be exposed and it
is worth noting that along with
transparency and permeation this is the
third port on this list that is most
effectively used when its user is naked
clearly horikoshi has a thing for
leaving his characters without clothes
now just imagine shopping on Amazon and
then instead of placing the order you
just create the item yourself without
having to pay or wait for delivery
but even crazier than that there is no
reason to think that Momo couldn't
simply create a whole bunch of gold and
use it to make herself extremely wealthy
after all you can Google the atomic
makeup of gold in only a few seconds and
if Momo knows the atomic makeup of a
material she should be able to make it
appear for this reason I think that
creation would be the most useful quirk
to have in the real world not only is it
convenient in all sorts of situations
from creating a spare key if you're
locked out of the house to creating
rollerskates when you just don't feel
like walking anymore but you can also
use it to make yourself rich out of all
the awesome perks on this list this
would probably be my first choice for a
quirk to possess in real life but it is
a close call let me know what your
choices are down below and that is it
our top 10 best and most useful quirks
for real life what are your thoughts are
there any useful quirks that you want to
see us include in the next video if this
video gets a whole bunch of likes we
will definitely make a part 2 and we
hope to include some of your suggestions
in that video as well so please feel
free to leave them in the comments as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you're new to the channel don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more my hero
academia and other anime content and
until next time see us faze Cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]